أجنبي
[موسيقى]
ER للغزلان العربية
ما تسميه أول
نادي مالكي سيارات الخارق للسيدات في دبي
[موسيقى]
يقودني هو علاج هو
علاجي يذهب بعض الناس ويتأملون بعض
الناس يمارسون اليوجا من أجلي  إيقاف التشغيل
هو أن تقود السيارة أن الإثارة لا تشبه
أي شيء آخر
[موسيقى
] تستعد
لرالي Road Rally Gumball 3000 لمسافات طويلة.
تشتهر Gumball جيدًا في عالم
Supercar Enthusiast ، أعني أن هذا
هو نوع قائمة الجرافات من التجمع أو الجولة
أن على المرء أن ينطلق
للمرة الأولى على الإطلاق في الشرق الأوسط
، يبدأ الرالي عادةً في لندن
هذا العام ، ويبدأ في الشرق الأوسط
بدءًا من برج بارك بطريق
يأخذ السائقين حوالي 3000 ميل
عبر الإمارات العربية المتحدة وسلطنة عمان.
نوع من الانفتاح
ومن الجيد أن تكون جزءًا من تلك الرياضة
والموسيقى والسيارات لديها هذه القدرة على نوع
من آه دعنا نقول فتح الأبواب بين
البلدان وهي في الواقع
نوع من الموصل الثقافي العظيم
رائد الأعمال Maximilian Cooper fo
ألهمت المسيرة في 1999 المستوحاة من رحلة برية
عبر أوروبا مع الأصدقاء ،
يشارك الحدث السنوي اسمه مع
فيلم 1976 The Gumball Rally حول
سباق الطرق عبر البلاد في الولايات
المتحدة
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
كان أول رالي Gumball هو كما تعرف
تجربة تعليمية رائعة بالنسبة لي ولكنها
كانت غير معروفة حقًا ، أعني التقدم السريع
لعقدين من الزمن ولقد بنينا للتو
سمعة لكوننا من
أشهر ما نقوم
به ، يجذب الرالي The Who's Who من
الموسيقيين والممثلين والرياضيين حول
العالم  هذا العام ، قاد فرنش مونتانا سيارة
رولز رويس وفيلي الشاب من
لامبورغيني
أنا أقود سيارة فيراري روما
[موسيقى]
كل عام أتطلع حقًا إلى مجرد
نوع من الجمع بين هذا النوع
من الأشخاص معًا
[الموسيقى]
وهذا هو ما يحصل أولاً  لاعبي ألعاب الوقت
مثل حنان متحمسون للمجتمع بعد كل شيء ،
لا يوجد فائزون حقيقيون هنا فقط
السباقات التي تجسد روح التواجد
خلف عجلة القيادة أنا أتطلع حقًا
إلى مقابلة رئيس البنزين من
كل مكان  r حول العالم وأنا
أتطلع على وجه التحديد للقاء النساء
السائقات
[موسيقى]
نحب أن نحب ذلك
[الموسيقى]